we're now more than six months into the
covid19 vaccine rollout here in nevada
but the shots are still not available
for young kids orco manna joins us live
with when that could possibly happen
and how parents and experts feel about
it orco
well brian right now only those aged 12
and under will be able to get the kova
19 vaccine
but it's still unclear when younger kids
will be able to get it
experts say it's important that they do
but parents we spoke to
are split they're not protected yet
diego trujillo's two sons are six and
nine years old neither has gotten the
covet 19 vaccine since it hasn't been
approved yet for those under the age of
12.
with the spike in the new the new
variants and everything that's occurring
that's
kind of been one of my biggest concerns
that's why trujillo can't wait until his
sons get their shot
it'll bring a large relief for me when
i'm finally able to get them vaccinated
other parents are planning to wait
michelle ballan has an eight and a
nine-year-old
i just don't think there's enough data
based on any you know to be able to
look at any short-term or long-term
effects right now
scientists are studying the vaccine's
impact on young kids
those clinical trials have given us the
information on the safety of the
efficacy
infectious disease epidemiologist brian
labis tells me getting kids immunized
will help our fight against the virus
especially in light of lagging
vaccination rates in nevada
we want a significant proportion of our
total population
protected against carbon so that if the
disease is spreading
it can't spread through any of those
children for those over age 12
especially boys there have been some
cases of myocarditis or heart
inflammation
after getting the vaccine but they're
mild the risk is much lower of getting
it from the vaccine than if you were to
be infected naturally
many parents ready to weigh the risks
and benefits i really want to see these
vaccines come through now there's still
no timeline for the completion of those
vaccine trials for younger kids
but on pfizer's website they say that
they hope to
submit the vaccine for emergency youth
authorization
by september or october reporting live
in the newsroom tonight orco mana 8 news
now